ciao a tutti ragazzi è benvenuta questo
è un video sono fa vj e oggi siamo sud
ricomincia ragazzi ve lo spiego young
stomp è un gioco malvagio cioè nel senso
per persone cattive avete presente tutti
quei momenti della vita del quale vi
sentite anche per un solo secondo
oggi racchiude tutti quei momenti
insieme quanti ragazzi a partire per
questo incredibile al bel cervello di un
oled che vediamo se riusciamo completa
al primo livello i primi livelli per
ricevere il tuo scintillante premio
siamo partiti cosa devo fare
devo alzare le scatole mettere questo
brano siccome la scatola c'è scritto che
va messa di sopra io adesso la capovolgo
ecco se ce l'ho fatta perché io so fare
il cattivo ragazzo cos'è sta roba da
tirare fuori il segnalibro che si non
riuscirei qui a leggere not to me not
corso proprio malvagio dentro c'è un
cestino tira l'acqua però non è il bagno
delle donne quindi devo alzare la
tavoletta perché sono una persona
cattiva
ecco ci devo alzare proprio tutto ecco
esatto così cadono nel cesso esatto io
faccio del male alle persone cosa c'è
una coppa dentro ma [ __ ] questo è
ciò che ha ricevuto per essere un mostro
eppure è il premio calcolo di iniziale
perché è bello porca vacca come luminoso
proprio come l'aveva descritto zio noi
continuiamo ragazzi perché io so di
poter far di peggio come facevo a farlo
negativo che ne so io mamma perdonami
por mi vida loca c'è una o un chicco
d'uva verde e dell'uva rossa ma io
quello verde lo metto in quella rossa
sono un pochettino morto dentro è lo zio
e sono cose che colpiscono il cuore che
lo capisco don't touch tag l'iphone
ok aria come ayale un font troppo bello
cioè dobbiamo metano è uno che fa cagare
il cazzo quindi comic sans che si usa
alle scuole medie perfetto era merda
spiego io è perché è una merda il comic
sans è talmente basilare che fa schifo
bravo comic sans sono proprio cattivo
tetris ragazzi no dall'altra parte
dall'altra parte
e come se qualcuno avesse rischiato su
una lavagna con le unghie domino lo
butta giù adam non ho mai visto una
mente così malvagie né hitler in
confronto era un bravo ragazzo
odio gli slip come fai a dormire la
notte gara non lo so ciò gli incubi
quotazioni 2016 per il nuovo presidente
degli stati uniti d'america sono tutti
uomini tranne questa che è una donna
quindi io voglio un presidente donna
quel click mi ha dato il cancro ma la
parola cancro non è usata la gli haters
quando si sentono più ritardati del
solito perché l'hanno messa in un cazzo
di gioco sapete quale sarebbe stata la
scelta ancora peggiore come presidente
dico
esatto i sandali li odio ma popoli iodio
a prescindere ma se c'è una cosa che
oggi di più sono i sandali con le calze
è orribile e la casa più questo più i
risvolti ni
vi prego qualcuno lo si vesta così ad
halloween di più 4 ma perchè vi prego
datemi do voglio mettere il più 4
qualcuno sei un mostro comprerei questo
gioco su steam ovviamente me lo chiedi
dopo zio perché non sa però credimi
invece lo farai grazie di avermelo detto
probabilmente ci farò un pensierino zio
ci sono i lego oh mio dio devo
ammetterlo tipo al pavimento
anche se lo schiacci col piede ti
ammazzi ok ho capito devo trovare equa e
non era a caccia insomma ma [ __ ]
masters 100 per cento ce l'ho fatta
ragazzi che lo fa è stato difficile è
stato molto difficile dare il massimo
della mia malvagità però sono contento
di averlo fatto rifatte dei crediti
posso insultarvi che già che ci sono che
chi ha fatto il gioco art non jane
heymans cioè il nome di merda vitali jv
vitali j
hai presente che i nomi con l'aie la
gente io detengo il copyright vero zio
quindi [ __ ]
quindi ragazzi spero che questo video vi
sia servito la lezione perché comunque
non si smette mai di imparare come
essere cattivi è un'altra roba
questo è cattiva se vedete i mobili
tavoli postate li rispetto a dove sono
così la gente perché insomma ragazzi
dentro ognuno di noi c'è della pura
malvagità quest'anno e questo è un dato
di fatto di sempre i ragazzi spero che
video vi sia piaciuto un mi piace se
anche voi siete malvagi anche voi
lasciate la tavola
detta del cesso alzata anche se siete
donne fra cassis alzate alla tavoletta
l'eccesso per far del male a voi stesse
quando vi truccate cosa del genere vole
dovete essere belle per chi per voi
stesse stessa cosa quando siete malvagie
dovete essere malvagio e non per le
altre persone ma per voi stesse ora che
mi serve cento a causa intravede
piaciuto aggiornamento mi piace alla
pagina di facebook come limitato la tana
descrizione censiti siete riusciti
diavolo prossimo vinto sempre cattivi da
ragazzo